we've just got news of some more
cutscenes from it including an extended
quarry scene with a funny moment from
Eddie and a creepy sounding Bar Mitzvah
ceremony involving Stan yippee-ki-yay
movie lovers it's Jan here and today I'm
talking about several deleted scenes
likely to appear in the director's cut
that's just been announced for the new
it's movie director and a machete
revealed that we can look forward to
around 15 minutes of extra footage and
his extended cut that will be appearing
on the blu-ray release just before I
jump in quick warning that I'll be
discussing spoilers from the movie so
take care if you've not seen it yet also
keep watching for details on the winner
of my Pennywise Funko pop giveaway the
first cutscene that Andy machete
revealed in an interview with Yahoo
movies is where Stan addresses the
guests at his Bar Mitzvah ceremony and
he delivers a speech where he basically
blames all the adults in derry for the
murders and disappearances in the town
machete also said this deleted scene has
a great resolution which makes me wonder
whether it's because penny wise or the
creepy woman who terrorized him
previously suddenly appears in the
congregation at the synagogue while he's
giving his speech if you remember in the
theatrical release Stan had his first
encounter with it at the beginning of
the movie by the creepy woman who
emerged from the painting at the
synagogue where he was practicing for
his Bar Mitzvah so perhaps the evil
entity it makes an appearance again to
disrupt Stan's speech or to turn the
crowd at the synagogue against him
it is often present and airy whenever an
ER if event is happening or about to
happen for example there was the scene
where Henry Bowers and his gang were
beating up Ben on the bridge and a pair
of adults drive by and just look away as
they drive past penny wises signature
balloon floats up inside the car showing
how it is at work making people either
blind to the violence or just
normalizing it I also wonder whether
Stan's attempt to reveal this truth
about it is the reason why penny wise
specifically targets him later and tries
to eat him when the losers go down into
the sewers to find Bev let me know if
you've got any theories about the scene
I certainly can't wait to see it in full
on the blu-ray machete has also revealed
that he enjoys filming alternate takes
and honest he gave the actors freedom to
improvise during their scenes as an
example of this the director explained
that he filmed a really funny extended
scene at the moment where the losers
off the cliff into the quarry water
below in the movie Eddie been Bill Stan
and Richie a standing on the cliff above
the quarry having a spitting match and
arguing over who should jump first
before Bev turns up and jumps in ahead
of them all in the extended scene the
moment was opened up and according to
machete after the spitting contest it
escalates into something that is
completely weird and is so funny
Jack grazer who plays Eddie does
something that is completely bonkers
I wonder if this deleted moment will
show the boys taking their competitive
nature's to even greater extremes in the
spitting contest or could an earlier
script give a clue as to what this
deleted moment might be in that earlier
screenplay at this moment in the film
Eddie worries about whether it's safe
for Ben to go in the water because of
his Kurtz and Richie tells him to shut
up and stop going on about gray water
which is what Eddie had been unhappy
about earlier in the movie when they
were in the sewers so I'm thinking that
the extended joking-around by Eddie
could riff on this sharing an even more
exaggerated side of his hypochondria
after all it seems like Jack who plays
Eddie has a real flair for working in
the moment as according to coast
screenwriter Gary Doberman that line
were Eddie mistakes the word gazebo for
placebo was also something that just
happened on the day according to
producer Barbara machete several scenes
featuring bill's parents were also cut
from the theatrical release though
they'll likely appear on the DVD in the
final film the scene where bill has made
a model of the Derry sewers in the
family garage shows us that there's a
conflict between Bill and his father
who's exasperated by his son's belief
that Georgie is still alive however
further moments were deleted from the
movie that focused on the growing
distance between Bill and his parents
after the traumatic disappearance of
Georgie speaking to Collider producer
machete said that the cut scenes show
bill trying to make their situation
better but his parents are just unable
to cope by the way when I was reading an
earlier script for the movie I noticed
that it included a scene where bill
speaks to his parents about planning
their annual trip to Acadia National
Park but neither his mother nor father
can faith even thinking about something
they're missing Charles loved so much
and they end up walking away leaving
bill alone in the room so I'm guessing
this is a kind of scene which machete is
referring to as having been given the
chop from the theatrical release now are
you excited
the director's cut of it and which
actors would you like to play the adult
losers in Chapter two and looking
forward to your thoughts in the comments
below you can also follow me on twitter
and my handles are on the screen here if
you enjoyed this don't forget to hit the
thumbs up button and subscribe and check
out some more videos you might like hear
the winner of my penny wise Funko pop
giveaway is on the screen right now so
if that's you send me a message with
your details and I'll get the price sent
out to you thanks for watching and see
you next time you became movie lovers